sur les extraits de vidéosurveillance
l'homme marche d'un bon pas il ne fuit
pas ne fait aucun geste bizarre pourtant
ces images ont été enregistrées près du
lieu de la première agression
les enquêteurs sont quasiment certain
qu'il s'agit de l'homme qu'ils
recherchent activement depuis six jours
il espère susciter davantage de
témoignages en donnant à voir et
entendre le maximum de détails sur
l'auteur présumé de ces attaques au
marteau l'homme visiblement jeunes de
corpulence fine à la peau plutôt claire
vêtu sombrement
porte un bonnet 13 ans fausse un front
foncé sur le crâne des baskets blanches
de marque semble-t-il nike et un sac à
dos sur les épaules de marque puma
les autorités ont également diffusé le
portrait-robot d'un homme habillé de
sombre aperçu sur l'île saint-laurent
peu après les faits son comportement a
intrigué un témoin le degré de certitude
qu'il s'agit là de l'agresseur est
moindre que dans le cas des vidéo de
caméra-surveillance mais les enquêteurs
veulent explorer toutes les pistes alors
que de nombreuses questions restent
encore sans réponse
tant qu'on n'aura pas interpeller
l'auteur ses motivations son profil
psychologique nous sont inconnus donc je
ne peux répondre à la question de savoir
si la motivation est terroriste ou si
c'est le fait de quelqu'un qui souffre
de problèmes psy de fait la sphère est
toujours piloté par le parquet de chalon
sur saône est confié à des enquêteurs du
commissariat de chalon et de la police
judiciaire de dijon un numéro a été mis
en place pour tout élément susceptible
de faire progresser l'enquêté